[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning the
federal government's newest jobs report
out this morning reveals a slowing
recovery from the impact of the
coronavirus
the labor department says the u.s
economy added nearly 1.8 million
jobs in july it did beat expectations
from 1.6
the unemployment rate fell to 10.2
percent
but that is down from the june numbers
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger
joins us now joe what do you make of
these numbers so far
well i mean these numbers were very
difficult to predict
so here's what you want to remember that
the virus
surge in the south and the west caused
a lot of municipalities to change their
rules they were slowing down their
reopening process
and of course consumers and businesses
in those places
also had to adjust and this meant that
the pace of job growth really did
slow down remember back in the beginning
of this
virus march and april 22 million jobs
lost
then we saw in may and june
seven and a half million jobs created
which is fantastic
now we're slowing down a bit it's
probably because of the spread of this
virus
the unemployment rate coming down is
certainly a good sign but i also like to
look at
the broader unemployment rate it
captures a lot of people who are working
part-time when they really like
full-time work
that rate now is down at about 16 and a
half percent
now again that's a higher number but it
peaked at about 22-23
back in the spring so directionally
things are in the right direction
it's just the pace of improvement has
slowed down and jill how much of this
is the economy that was due for a
recession versus pandemic
well this is clearly pandemic related i
mean there is no doubt that when you see
22 million jobs vaporize over the course
of two months
that that is because the entire nation
shut down
however i think the reopening process
is starting to actually weed out a lot
of different businesses
so businesses who came into the period
very shaky
you're going to see them to their you're
going to see their failures
you're going to see big department
stores who maybe have a lot of debt
they're not going to make it you may see
mom and pop
restaurants that were operating on razor
thin margins
they may not make it so in fact the
pandemic's probably an accelerant
to what was going on previously it's
been a lot of talk about the
the uh the debate over the new uh
potential new stimulus package here
uh joe which has still not happened or
no agreement has been made
and a lot of talk about whether the
larger checks or the extra checks that
are going to people are discouraging
them from going back to work there is
some new research out on that what is it
what does it tell you
we actually see no correlation between
higher unemployment benefits and people
looking for work
in fact it's quite the opposite when
people are making more money
they have time to sit down look through
their options and actually
seek employment and there is a study
that's out from yale that confirms this
we see some research from the federal
reserve banks there's also an
interesting paper just out from the
national
bureau of economic research and they
were looking back
at the great recession of 2008 and 2009
when benefits were not just bigger but
extended for a longer period of time
and that paper found something really
very critical
and that is when people have a longer
period of time to look for work and the
security of unemployment benefits
they find a better job for them their
skills match the job that's out there
that's important because we actually
don't want people taking jobs
that may be below their skill level
because that takes the job away from
somebody at that skill level
so in fact richer and longer
unemployment benefits
may be the key to recovering in the
labor market more quickly
all right and jill so it also worth the
new york fed
reported that household debt in the
middle of all this household that
actually decreased in the second quarter
can you talk about that
well this had a lot to do with credit
card debt and credit card debt shrunk
for the first time
in six years and the largest decline in
seven years that has a lot to do with
people just not wanting to spend money
but also remember those twelve hundred
dollar stimulus checks a lot of people
use that money to pay down outstanding
debt
look as a certified financial planner
that's great economists don't love this
they want to see people spend more
freely
obviously as the economy starts to
loosen up and return to more normal
levels
many think that these debt levels will
rise once again jeff
okay jill schlesinger as always thank
you very much
take care